David Boder: [In English] Munich, September the 24th, 193—, 1946, at the UNNRA University for displaced persons at the Deutsches Museum. The interviewee is now Nathan Finkel from Rovno, a Jewish student at the university. He will speak Russian.
David Boder: [In Russian] Аг, скол...Сколько вам лет?
Nathan Finkel: Мне 26 лет.
David Boder: Так. Ну, [садитесь и?] [неразборчиво] а говорите так, что [неразборчиво]. Скажите пожалуйста где вы были когда война началась.
Nathan Finkel: Когда война началась, я был в Ровне.
David Boder: Так. А были Русские в Ровне перед войной?
Nathan Finkel: [неразборчиво]
David Boder: Нет, нет, нет. Я думаю [неразборчиво] когда Ровно было в Польше.
Nathan Finkel: Да. В Польше было.
David Boder: Ну, так. Когда немцы вошли [заикающийся] в западную Польшу. Русские вошли, аг, немцы вошли в Ровно или русские вошли в Ровно?
Nathan Finkel: В западную Польшу вошли в 39-ом году немцы.
David Boder: Нет, они зашли...они зашли в восточную Польшу.
Nathan Finkel: В восточную [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так и по-этому я и говорю: Русские вошли в восточную Польшу. Ну, хорошо. Вы [неразборчиво] этого времени и продолжайте тогда, скажите мне что с вами случилось?
Nathan Finkel: С 39-ого года я занимался в Ровне, потом уехал в 40-ом году в [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Ну, подождите-ка. Русские вошли в Ровно когда?
Nathan Finkel: В сентябре 39-ого года.
David Boder: Стоп! Что тогда произошел?
Nathan Finkel: Тогда я из семьи [неразборчиво]. Мы все остались на месте.
David Boder: Так.
Nathan Finkel: Опять получил работу. Я уехал в Львов заниматься. Учился в политехнике в Львове.
David Boder: И русские взяли Львов тоже?
Nathan Finkel: Тоже. И тоже западную Украину.
David Boder: Так. [прерывая друг друга] Западная Украина и...
Nathan Finkel: [прерывающий] Западная Украина и восточная Польша.
David Boder: Так.
Nathan Finkel: [неразборчиво]
Nathan Finkel: В 41-ом году, в июне когда началась война между Германией а Россией, я на [неразборчиво] после начала войны, я ушел в Ровно. В Ровне был 3 месяцы всего, потому что начались очень большие преследования [неразборчиво] немцами...Немцами.
David Boder: Так.
Nathan Finkel: Все убрали до работы уже 6 месяцев после начала войны. Аг. В декабре месяце они уже 17,000 в течение [недели одней?] убили евреев.
David Boder: Как они убили их?
Nathan Finkel: Они [делили?] с утра всем собраться на площади только с [неразборчиво] и больше ничего нельзя было взять с собой.
David Boder: Так.
Nathan Finkel: И после всех [неразборчиво] [только вышел?], это были те которые не работали.
Nathan Finkel: И [неразборчиво] уйти, значит от эссэсс, эссэссов [сошли?]
David Boder: Так.
Nathan Finkel: Их возили 6 километров за город. Там уже были приготовлены место для них и 3 дня стреляли и всех уже [в ям?], в ямы там, скинули и закопали.
Nathan Finkel: Я...
David Boder: [прерывающий] Кто копал эти ямы и кто...
Nathan Finkel: [прерывающий] Явно копали украинцы.
David Boder: Так...Ну, дальше.
Nathan Finkel: [Им?] занимались украинцы только, а немцы только [стреляли?]. [То есть, немцы?] приказывали. Немцы имели [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так.
Nathan Finkel: Они только приказывали. Немци [так?].
David Boder: Так. Ну, дальше.
Nathan Finkel: Ну я уже в Ровне тогда не был.
David Boder: А, где вы были?
Nathan Finkel: Я тогда убежал и еще на месяц от этого, убежал в западную Польшу.
David Boder: Так.
Nathan Finkel: Там с евреями было немного лучше, потому что...
David Boder: [прерывающий] В западную Польшу [неразборчиво]?
Nathan Finkel: В западную Польшу. Я убежал в город Сосновиец.
David Boder: [неразборчиво]. Так.
Nathan Finkel: Да, на Силезию. Там уже гетто было, я находился в гетте полтора года. Работал в [Скопе?], это по-немецки называли ее.
David Boder: Да.
Nathan Finkel: С утра до вечера очень тяжело и нам была особенно с пищей очень плохо.
David Boder: Ну...
Nathan Finkel: Так. , потому что немцы очень мало для геттов оставляли. Уже в э— [заикающийся] в этом времени начинали [взять?] в концлагеря. Этих местностей [брали?] arbeitslagerы, значит там работали мы. [Мне?] также в 43-ем году собрали мы вместе с братом и находился я в лагере Гросс Росен на Силезии. Все время работал. Работал очень тяжело. Конечно [в селе?] [неразборчиво] [мы уже стали плохие-то?] только могут быть два человека. В бараках мы жили. Пище было очень плохо, заболевали и сотни умирали там. В одной комнате могут находиться по 100 человек, а на заводе, на фабрике, где мы работали были такие площадки мы [строили заботы?]. Очень тяжело. С нами немцы очень плохо относились.
Nathan Finkel: Работал я [всего же не имел?]. Последние два месяца перед концом войны, я уже думал, что конец со мной,, потому что несколько раз заболел, только [из-за их?] [неразборчиво] из-за слишком тяжелой работы. Работал на площадке.
David Boder: Что значит “на площадке”?
Nathan Finkel: На площадке этого строительства. Строительство военного завода. Со мной были несколько товарищей и они все погибли, потому что я был немного [попятствее??], мне удалось пережить. Мы питали кавы. Там много было кавы, это [шараговая?] кавы. Из этого [неразборчиво] гораздо заболевал...
David Boder: [прерывающий] вы думаете?
Nathan Finkel: [прерывающий] Кофе, кофе. Да.
David Boder: Так.
Nathan Finkel: И до этого очень много умирали. [и мешали геморрои?], а после операции не [делали?] и умирали. В другом, на Силезии там было очень много лагерей.
Nathan Finkel: Работали там девушки. Большинства, они работали на фабриках...
David Boder: [неразборчиво]?
Nathan Finkel: Я в лагере этом в Гросс Росен находился до марта 45-ого года. В марте начали немцы нас [неразборчиво].
David Boder: [Сколько?] этот раз вы были в Гросс Росене?
Nathan Finkel: В этом раз я был в Росене полтора года.
David Boder: Так.
Nathan Finkel: [Эвакуировали?] нас на запад. Я попал в Бухенвальд.
Nathan Finkel: В Бухенвальде ужасно было. Там сотни, тысячи людей, все находились там в ужасных условиях, потому что тогда переводились и не был в лагере здоровых, другой, потому что немцы бежали перед русскими. Все боялись. Мы в Бухенвальде тоже почти день и ночь находились под [огнем неба?], потому что помещений для нас не было. Так сам [успешно?] [неразборчиво] хуже. [Есть ожидает до время?] до марта 45-ого года многие сохранились [свои жизни?]. Так, последний месяц, особенно в последние дни [тысяча?] погибали [в день?], потому что [неразборчиво] не нас возили [мы с ним ехали?], а ходили пешком. Так, по дороге кто только оказывал слабость [неразборчиво], сразу убивали. Убивали. Так, что по дороге все меньше и меньше остано...остановились.
David Boder: Так, вот, аг, аг, вы были в Бухенвальде.
Nathan Finkel: Да. Только полтора месяца был.
David Boder: Так.
Nathan Finkel: [Я был там в конце войны?]. [Качество записи становится хуже.] Ну, тогда нас освободили и я конечно находился здесь в американской зоне.
David Boder: Так. Ну сейчас [неразборчиво] в американской зоне [неразборчиво] расскажите подробно [неразборчиво].
Nathan Finkel: Я с самого начала освобождения находился в лагере Фельдафинг. Это был специальный лагерь для евреев. Там находился [неразборчиво] [6,000?]. Условия были [неразборчиво] [нехороший?] [неразборчиво]. Американцы старались [во всяком?] [неразборчиво] [со мной?].
David Boder: Кто основал Фельдафинг?
Nathan Finkel: Фельдафинг основали Американцы.
David Boder: Вы знаете [неразборчиво].
Nathan Finkel: Нет, не знаю.
David Boder: Так, [неразборчиво.]
Nathan Finkel: [неразборчиво] Ну, потому что я пришел [позже?], я [не избежал самого начала?] и [тоже?] тогда не было.
David Boder: Так. Да.
Nathan Finkel: Я там находился в этом же лагере до января 46-ого года. В январе 46-ого года я узнал, что здесь [неразборчиво] университет. Я решил сюда приехать Мюнхен, чтобы заниматься. Получил квартиру и марта месяца [прерывая друг друга]. Частную квартиру получил.
David Boder: Вам назначали немцы?
Nathan Finkel: Мне назначали немцы, да, частную квартиру. Хорошую комнату.
David Boder: Вы что, холостяк?
Nathan Finkel: Я холостяк. Имею брата здесь. Больше никого из семи не имею.
David Boder: Откуда же брата [взял?]?
Nathan Finkel: Брат был все время со мной, в лагере тоже. [Из Щечина?] были вместе. И здесь так [неразборчиво] все время...
David Boder: [прерывающий] Брат что делает?
Nathan Finkel: Брат тоже занимается здесь в университете [неразборчиво] [на втором?]...
David Boder: [прерывающий] Аг, вы чему учитесь?
Nathan Finkel: Я учусь архитектуре.
David Boder: Так, что...хорошо...значит, брат [неразборчиво] [по следующей пошли?]?
Nathan Finkel: Заниматься.
David Boder: Так...Ну, а как [эти?] условия в университете, вы, аг, что...
Nathan Finkel: Условия в университете не очень так хорошие потому, теперь [неразборчиво], но раньше [с пищей?] не было так хорошо. Что касается занятий, это основной. У нас на архитектуре студентов здесь всего 70. Профессора всего несколько хороших, остальные не [учет нас очень многими?] до исключения нескольких.
David Boder: А, как отношение между студентами?
Nathan Finkel: Между студентами отношение довольно корректное. Хотя я еврей, [и чувствую?]
David Boder: [неразборчиво].
Nathan Finkel: И чувствую, что здесь очень много есть моих самых, аг, таких врагов, самых таких [зарядившихся?] врагов, ну все-таки, я этого никогда не чувствую.
David Boder: Вы как? Вы чувствуете или не чувствуете?
Nathan Finkel: Я чувствую, потому что знаю, что они [неразборчиво], ни это [не доказывают?] отношение ко мне. [Наруже?] этого не видит.
David Boder: Так...Может быть это просто ваша подозрительность?
Nathan Finkel: Это...Может быть вся моя подозрительность, но так как я узнаю, что здесь украинцы, что здесь литовцы. Они были наши убийцы, потому что нас не немцы убивали, а только украинцы и литовцы и все.
David Boder: Но литовцы только беженцы?
Nathan Finkel: Не все бежы.
David Boder: Ну, понял...дальше.
David Boder: Ну, и что вы ожидаете от этого университета? У вас родственники в Америке есть?
Nathan Finkel: У меня есть родственники, но я о них очень мало знаю. И как [исправление] пока не связался еще с ними. Я думаю заниматься, пока что здесь условия есть лучшие чем [те где-нибудь в стране?], так я хочу здесь учиться.
David Boder: Ага, а почему [ведь на местный?] университет не пойдете?
Nathan Finkel: Я теперь поступаю.
David Boder: Какой?
Nathan Finkel: С немецкими [сейчас Мюнхен?] после второго семестра.
David Boder: В архитектуре?
Nathan Finkel: В архитектуре, да.
David Boder: А кто это для вас платить будет?
Nathan Finkel: [Для нас платить мы?] освободили.
David Boder: И...
Nathan Finkel: [прерывающий] Всех еврейских студентов [освобожден?] оплатить.
David Boder: Кто это освободил вас?
Nathan Finkel: Освободил нас наш союз студенческий, который здесь находится.
David Boder: [Этот союз?] еврейский?
Nathan Finkel: Это специальный еврейский союз находится здесь 210 студентов евреев. Раньше все почти были здесь на УННРА университете. Теперь большинство [перенесет?] в немецкий университет. Так как сам и условия на у— [остановками], условия лучше
David Boder: Так.
Nathan Finkel: Здесь не всех приспособлений не нужно, потому что этот университет [здесь нарастает остальных?]...
David Boder: Да.
Nathan Finkel: . . . переставят. А там уже [все?] на местные профессора [во первых лучше?].
David Boder: Так.
Nathan Finkel: С другой стороны там [неразборчиво] [учиться?] так как мы [находимся в связей?] немцы.
David Boder: А вы думаете, что немецкие студенты такие же плохие как они были при Гитлере?
Nathan Finkel: Они остались все-таки [эти скисания?] , потому что [есть они?] явно этого не заговаривают, но чувствуется их [неразборчиво].
David Boder: [Кто это?] высказывает? Может быть вы просто подозрительные люди.
Nathan Finkel: Высказывается [в том?], что очень часто даже замечается как один указывает на другого что здесь слишком много [живущих?] евреев.
David Boder: А между прочим это освобождение отплаты, что [студенческий союз?] платить или немцы освободили отплаты?
Nathan Finkel: Немцы, государство баварское...
David Boder: Так.
Nathan Finkel: . . . освободило нас. Это [неразборчиво] [бундес-?] министр освободил...
David Boder: [прерывающий] А Украинцы не свободны от платы?
Nathan Finkel: Не все. [Не как?] [неразборчиво] мы.
David Boder: Или поляки?
Nathan Finkel: Тоже [они, но не все?], а еврейские освободили.
David Boder: Так, что вы думаете переместить в Мюнхенский университет?
Nathan Finkel: Да. Я уже [записался?]
David Boder: Есть ли что-нибудь, который вы захотели сказать американским или еврейским студентам в Америке?
Nathan Finkel: Есть.
David Boder: Скажите.
Nathan Finkel: Нам очень [неразборчиво] надо помочь. Особенно у нас нет книг. Если эта возможность у американских студентов, чтоб нам эти книги [переслать?]. Кроме того, мы хотим [набежать?] с ними отношения [писать им?], чтобы они нам тоже писали. [Менять опытом?]. Мы очень много конечно отстаем, так как 6 лет не занимались и [отстали вообще?] культуры и хотим все это теперь делать. У нас отношения [и условия?] очень, аг...
David Boder: Душевные.
Nathan Finkel: . . . душевные. Очень долго [занимают?].
David Boder: Скажите вот что. Вы знаете что такое Гилели фонд?
Nathan Finkel: Что такое Гилели фонд очень хорошо знаю, потому что здесь при [неразборчиво] Мюнхен. Этот представитель был Мистер [Десло?]. Он очень много [неразборчиво] себе еврейских студентов и говорил он им о Гилели фонд. Некоторые записали, особенно те, которые хорошо знают английский язык.
David Boder: А может быть [они в том?] [неразборчиво] записаться [неразборчиво].
Nathan Finkel: [прерывающий] Да.
David Boder: Гилели фонд ведь могло быть что-нибудь делать для вас всех.
Nathan Finkel: Пока очень мало сделали, за исключением того, что Мистер, Мистер [Десло?] нам рассказывал об этом и студенты записывали. До сих пор еще ничего...
David Boder: [прерывающий] Они организации тут не устроил.
Nathan Finkel: Не устроили ничего. А нам [неразборчиво] очень много нам надо помочь, потому что никаких почти условий [неразборчиво] нет. Теперь УННРЫ помогает нам. Все будет после этого...
David Boder: [прерывающий] Ну, я думаю, что это как [студенческий интервью?]. Я бы хотел с вами говорить значительно дольше. Ну, время...[запись заканчивается внезапно]